So guys, terrible
news-- turns out I
didn't win the Powerball
drawing this week.
So close, yet oh, so, so, far.
Hey, folks.
Laci Green here with another
D News Update for you.
We all know the odds
of winning the lottery
are extremely low-- like
extremely, holy crap,
I've never heard a statistic
so small in my life low.
Powerball reports its current
odds one in 175 million.
That means that you're
more likely to win
a gold medal in the Olympics,
more likely to win an Academy
Award, and more likely
to be hit by an asteroid,
but that one sucks, so
let's not think about it.
People who play the lottery
know the odds are low.
They may not realize how low,
but we know it's not likely.
And yet, more than
half the country
still plays, which is so
fascinating and bizarre to me.
Why do hundreds of
millions of people
play a game they'll never
win, a game in which you
have to completely ignore
logic, reason, and rationale
to play in the first place?
be something going
on here, right?
Of course, there always is.
Let's take a look at some
of the leading studies.
Robert Williams, a sociologist
who studies lotteries
at the University of Lethbridge,
says, one reason we play anyway
is the sheer brain fart
that these odds cause.
One in 175 million--
our brain just
can't understand how
small that number is.
It's totally abstract.
But you know what
isn't abstract?
Hopes and dreams, baby--
buying a nice home,
lounging on a tropical
beach forever,
not having to worry about
making next month's rent,
paying off that
enormous health care
bill, a convenient from
loans or credit card debt,
a convenient escape
from poverty.
It's all very real up
here-- much more real
than some incomprehensible
statistic.
These fantasies activate
areas of the brain linked
to motivation and
decision making.
And weighed against your
hope, a dollar or two
doesn't seem like much.
And shoot, a glitter
of hope sure is fun.
A new study published in the
Journal of Consumer Research
also found that fantasies
about specific material items,
like a car or a yacht, actually
break down our self control.
In the study, those who
bought a lottery ticket
with a specific item
in mind expressed
a greater affinity for
small, quick rewards
rather than bigger
but delayed rewards.
This break in self
control leads someone
who buys one lottery
ticket to buy more of them.
Another study at
Carnegie Mellon found
that feeling uncertain--
for instance, about
whether or not you
could be the lucky one--
cues the brain to
seek resolution.
That little voice
asking what could be,
what might have been
sometimes results
in what scientists
call magical thinking,
superstitious, the belief that
I personally am above the odds.
Magical thinking means the
brain finds an answer that
isn't grounded in reality,
but it feels good, anyway.
When you think about it,
it's applicable to a lot
of things, not just the lottery.
Pair these factors up with
all that sneaky but aggressive
marketing prompting
those fantasies,
instilling false
hope, egging you on,
and, well, you got $65 billion
being spent on lottery tickets
every year.
In the comments or on Twitter
@DNews, let me know-- have you
ever played the lottery?
What are some of
the other reasons
that we play against
all the odds?
Thanks for tuning in, folks.
I'll catch you next time.